good morning at six o'clock we are
starting with breaking news near
summerlin roads closed right now after a
very serious car crash it happened early
this morning about 3 30. this is
charleston and wallapie mary jane
belliesa just arrived there at the scene
joining us now with what she's learned
so far mary jane
john and heather good morning we are
here on hualapai where both lanes are
closed due to a car crash you can
already see one vehicle there behind me
police tape has crossed off the scene
this is right off hualapay on both lanes
near charleston we're located right off
that smith's parking lot area right
across the street from the hualapai
animal hospital again we're still
working to
gather more details for you about what
had happened here but so far it seems
like one car right now is involved it
has been blocked off for this area and
again if you are planning on taking this
route to your morning commute make sure
you find another way through this area
could be closed for quite some time and
again we're still working to figure out
more details here this happened around 3
30 this morning again both lanes are
closed off hualapai and near charleston
again if you're planning on moving this
way for your morning commute find
another area expect this area to be
closed and we'll continue to gather
those details for you on air and online
reporting live near charleston huawei
mary jean vallieza live local now